was sagt ihnen eigentlich momentan ihr
bäcker in thüringen in ihrem wahlkreis
mit dem habe ich heute geredet aber
nicht nur mit einem sondern tatsächlich
mit mehreren heute den ganzen nachmittag
ist nicht wahr was sage ja
die sagen sie sind auf der einen seite
sehr verunsichert das ja klar sie sagen
sie benötigten hilfe sie sehen aber auch
dass die bundesregierung danach schaut
und was man tun kann und dass die
mittelständischen unternehmen die
kleinen wie die bäckerin der bäcker
jetzt wirklich im fokus dessen sind was
wir brauchen und so eine idee wie basis
strom oder strompreis bremse wie auch
immer wir das nennen also ein grund
kontingent den niedrigen preis finden
die erst mal gut aber die haben
natürlich
einen großen berg vor sich die haben den
mindestlohn der kommt und das heißt ja
nicht nur das mindestlohn kommt was ja
richtig ist was die übrigens alle
richtig finden sondern das heißt eben
auch die anderen wohnung müssen steigen
und angepasst werden und die sind in
einer situation wo sie sagen wir wollen
weiter arbeiten wir sind übrigens
unternehmerinnen und unternehmer wir
wissen auch dass wir mit unsicheren
situationen zurechtkommen können und
müssen und sie vertrauen aber darauf
dass auf der einen seite sofort hilfe
kommt und auf der anderen seite das aber
auch klar sein muss wir müssen jetzt
längerfristig auch in veränderungen
kommen also diese frage wie sind die
energiepreise denn im nächsten jahr die
in steht genauso wie jetzt die ja aber
das wasser bis zum hals und herbig ist
heute zu zitieren damit dass allein bei
den gaspreisen vierstellige summen auf
den normalen einzelnen bürger zukommt
und offensichtlich hat er die kmu s also
die kleinen und mittelständischen
unternehmen vergessen hat er die
tatsächlich im regen stehen lassen oder
wäre das geschehen der diese woche der
eurotest nicht donnerstag gab gelegt er
hat ja nachgelegt und er hat auch sehr
deutlich gemacht natürlich brauchen wir
das auch für diese kleinen
mittelständischen unternehmen und was
wir jetzt ehrlich gesagt machen ist
schon eine andere form von politik wir
sitzen jetzt nicht irgendwie im
hinterzimmer oder verschlossen und dann
kommt irgendwas raus und das nicht denn
auf den tisch und das wird gemacht
sondern was wir tun es mit leuten reden
und sagen okay wenn es dieses problem
hier gibt dann wollen wir genau dafür
passgenau helfen aber es sollte ja
dieses wuchtige paket sein und dann
wurde ganz schön viel nachgebessert
allein in den ansagen nachbessern man
kann aber auch sagen es entwickelt sich
und wir haben eine krise wie wir sie so
noch nie hatten und deswegen ist es auch
gut dass wir weiter reden und nicht
sagen schluss aus ende das war's jetzt
sondern wenn wir eine weitere hilfe
brauchen wir haben jetzt das dritte
entlastungspaket der seele wie die zwei
ersten zusammen oder sogar noch mehr und
wenn man führt das brauchen gibson führt
ist wir reden über hilfe jetzt und sind
dankbar dafür dass er heute bei uns ist
siegfried russwurm der chef des bdi
ihnen muss man gratulieren heute sie
haben den ganz großen preis gewonnen sie
werden diese expertenkommission leiten
die nun bis oktober auch noch die
gaspreise stützen und retten soll sie
haben heraus vorgesagt es kommen schwere
zeiten auf uns zu und warnen vor einer
massiven rezession
wie kommen sie zu diesem befund nun
ähnlich wie frau gehört die letzten
wochen habe ich ganz viele anrufe
bekommen ganz viele briefe bekommen e
mails bekommen und irgendwann haben wir
beim bdi dann mal gesagt wir müssen
jetzt aus diesen anekdotischen
datenpunkten substanz gewinnen haben der
umfrage gemacht etwa 600
mittelständische unternehmerinnen und
unternehmer befragt mit ein paar
kernfragen wie geht's euch denn und was
tut ihr jetzt und die ergebnisse waren
schon also ernüchternd ist da ein
schwaches wort dafür man könnte auch
sagen beängstigend
nun ein drittel der befragten sagen wir
sind in einer existenziellen krise mit
unserem unternehmen und doch mal 58
prozent sagt wir sind unter immensen
druck also 90 prozent marke es ist die
ausnahme wenn ein unternehmen nicht in
der kriegssituation ist
20 prozent haben entweder schon
entschieden oder sind in überlegungen
produktion aus deutschland weg zu
verlagern und 40 prozent sagen in dieser
20 20 prozent und 90 prozent und jetzt
ein bisschen so aus meinen
unterhaltungen auch unternehmen wo ich
nie geglaubt hätten also so der typische
mittelstands patriot der das wirklich
nicht leichtfertig macht aber er sagt
ich habe keine andere chance wenn die
energiepreise in anderen ländern der
welt wo ich im globalen wettbewerb bin
um faktoren gering sind und was mich
besonders auch betroffen gemacht hat war
das 40 prozent sagen wir können uns
geplante investitionen in die
dekarbonisierung nicht leisten weil die
perspektive so unsicher ist dass wir das
geld zusammen dafür wirklich hilfe die
es ja heute auch hier sind noch mal bei
der frage die die insolvenz als die
unternehmen müssen in die insolvenz
gehen oder fürchten sie robert habeck
würde sagen sie stellen das arbeiten ein
am ende würde es für die beschäftigten
der selbe bedeuten da klappt da war auch
ein missverständnis in der öffentliche
diskussionen dabei manama gibt es die
option der insolvenz aber man sollte
nicht verkennen dass viele
mittelständler graf personen unternehmer
die warten nicht auf eine insolvenz die
kommen an dem punkt wo sie sagen es geht
nicht mehr weiter
die schließen ihren betrieb aber
endgültig und zahlen alle rechnungen die
wollen keine insolvenz in der kleinen
stadt in der sie leben die verkaufen
halt ihren ihre betriebs auto und
verkaufen die theke und vermieten
hoffentlich das ladenlokal irgendwie
weiter die melden nicht insolvenz an
deswegen nur auf diesen parameter wie
viele insolvenzen haben wir zu sagen den
sprung befindet leistungen im sinne von
betriebsaufgabe ist wahrscheinlich das
richtige wort dazu zählen wir sind bei
der vorsitzenden des deutschen
gewerkschaftsbundes vorfall nie sie
haben heute zum zweiten mal stichwort
konzertierte aktion im bundeskanzleramt
mit den arbeitgebervertretern beraten
sind beide seiten gleich
zornig auf die regierung nein zornig
sind wir alle nicht gewesen sondern es
ist glaube ich eher zu beschreiben eine
mischung aus einerseits anerkennung
vieler entscheidungen die getroffen
worden sind also es gibt ja nennenswerte
aktivitäten mit den drei
entlastungspaket aber gleichzeitig auch
eben genau noch einmal verdeutlichen
dass wir alle sehr in sorge sind mit
blick auf die wirtschaftliche situation
aber eben auch die situation in
privathaushalten ich darf noch einmal
sehr deutlich unterstreichen das wasser
steht nicht nur den betrieben bis zum
hals sondern bist irgendwie sozusagen
den normalverdiener die mittelschicht
dieses landes und deswegen bedarf es vor
allem einer senkung der energiepreise
weil das sind die haupt
inflationstreiber das ist die sozusagen
der der auch die jetzt der große
rezessions treiber insofern helfen keine
ökonomischen theorie debatten sondern
man muss jetzt sehr konkret hier das
problem an den wurzeln packen und das
heißt energiepreise runter manuela
schwesig ist bayerns ministerpräsident
von mecklenburg vorpommern wo
schließlich der chef von haacke sagt
hätten wir also toilettenpapier
hersteller hätten wir die staatshilfe
schneller bekommen wären wir jetzt nicht
zahlungsunfähig
der schnell hilft dir hilft
offensichtlich doppelt diese regierung
hilft nicht schnell genug und also nicht
die regierung hilft es ist ja gerade das
zweite große entlastungspaket gemacht
worden wo wir jetzt das dritte bestimmt
wo wir jetzt für die rentnerinnen und
rentner zum beispiel das energie geld
haben nachdem es jetzt auch die aber
nachdem es schon die arbeitnehmer und
familien bekommen wenn man zum beispiel
ein wichtiger punkt was die bürgerinnen
und bürger angeht aber was fehlt ist
wirklich eine konkrete hilfe für die
wirtschaft und ich will das mal
vergleich mit der krone pandemie da
waren wir auch in einer großen krise
wird aber nur und das war schon schwer
genug ein teil der wirtschaft betroffen
und zwar die die geschlossen war da hat
alleine der bund 70 milliarden euro
wirtschaftshilfen in die hand genommen
die ausländer haben dann auch oft noch
was drauf gelegt mit zusatzhilfe und wir
werden auch hier hilfen machen müssen
ich bin aber nicht dafür dass wir hinten
raus helfen mit sich an leistungspaketen
sondern wir unterstützen ganz klar das
modell des energiepreis deckels meine
landesregierung hat schon im märz
vorgeschlagen dass wir ein energiepreis
deckel brauchen und ich würde mich auch
gar nicht aus eine der cdu mit dem dgb
mit
damals waren es glaube ich dgb der
herausgegangen ist wir haben dann bei
uns im land ein genau in ein
energiegipfel gemacht weil ich finde es
reicht ja nicht wenn das einzelne
bereiche wollen sondern wir haben mit
allen im land gesprochen mit den kammern
mit den unternehmerverband also der
wirtschaft den gewerkschaften
sozialverbänden kommunen
verbraucherschutzzentralen stadtwerken
energieversorgern also alle die mit dem
thema zu tun haben und alle sind ganz
klar für den energiepreis decke weil wir
müssen diese preise wirklich deckeln
wenigsten jetzt erstmal auf sicht für
ein oder zwei jahre damit die leute
planungssicherheit bekommen das wasser
steht uns bis zum hals ich war dienstag
bei unserem becker vor ort in der
frühschicht ich komme gerade von einer
demonstration von über 1000 unternehmen
und unternehmern die wissen einfach
nicht wie sie es bezahlen sollen und so
geht es dem feuerwehrmann der jetzt
anstatt 100 euro 700 euro im monat sein
soll und so geht es dem bäckermeister
für den es jetzt auf einmal anstatt
20.000 euro nachher 120 und vielleicht
sogar 240.000 haben sie verständnis
dafür dass offensichtlich die klein und
mittelständischen betriebe dem
wirtschaftsminister da erst mal
durchgegangen sind und dass er nach
einer massiven protestwelle
diese hilfen und auch insolvenz anpasst
und gesetz anpassungen er ist nachlegte
ich finde es gut dass robert habeck
angekündigt hat dass wirtschaftshilfen
geben soll ich glaube nur dass wir schon
jetzt kommen die müssen jetzt komm ich
sage wir brauchen aber eine strukturelle
lösung wir machen doch ein systemwechsel
deutschland hat jahrzehnte auf
preiswertes russisches gas gesetzt da
kann man jetzt heute darüber diskutieren
wie man will das ist aber ein fakt zwar
dreimal preiswerter als angie gas und
wir werden nicht nur durch den krieg
sondern wir werden dauerhaft drei
steigungen haben und wir müssen hier die
unternehmen unterstützen auch wegen der
internationalen wettbewerbsfähigkeit wir
wollen gute löhne nicht nur den
mindestlohn wollen gute tariflöhne wir
wollen ein gutes sozialsystem also
arbeitslosenversicherung
pflegeversicherung krankenversicherung
jungs wo soll es runter gehen weil wir
es alles gut wollen wir hatten auf der
anderen seite preiswerte energie das ist
jetzt nicht mehr so das können wir
eigentlich erst wieder bekommen wenn wir
100 prozent schaffen energie unabhängig
zu werden
erneuerbaren energien ist aber noch ein
weg der weiterweg und für jede
zwischenzeit müssen wir es ab puffern
und das nach meiner tiefen überzeugung
gerade nach expertengesprächen die
einzige chance der energiepreis decke
ich würde jemand sagen was wir sind
nicht der wirtschaft die preise zu
deckeln sondern den grundbedarf
abzusichern genau das muss man erklären
das ist macht einen unterschied ob wir
jetzt diese berühmten zufalls gewinne
abschöpfen und darüber nachdenken dass
wir auf die art und weise preise der
senken deckel meint hier das ein grund
bedarf gestützt wird und subventioniert
wird und alles was darüber verbraucht
wird eben nicht herr vogel das ist nicht
das modell das die ampel entworfen hat
einen solchen grundbetrag an strom und
energie besser oder preiswerter zu
machen für jeden menschen und für jede
firma und alles was darüber bezahlt wird
teurer zu machen sondern ihr modell ist
oder war es bisher die preise erst mal
am markt wirken zu lassen und zu
subventionieren bei den besonders
bedürftigen unter waren große firmen
dabei unter waren rentner und bürger
dabei die jetzt ein energie geld bekamen
und es soll mehrwertsteuersenkung
hingeben auf den gaspreis aber man hätte
ja auch sagen können so ein gestützter
grundsockel sie verstehen die frage wie
alle diskutieren ja schon wochenlang
darüber würde erstmal jedem helfen und
er wäre auch versteht da und er würde
auch zum sparen anregen weil man würde
nicht wollen dass man über diesen sockel
kommt froh dass ihre antwort das ist ja
genau was sie mit der strompreis trennen
sie vorhaben also genau dass ich war
selber dabei im kanzleramt im
koalitionsausschuss haben wir ja lange
diskutiert auch vorher diskutiert was
müssen wir tun und natürlich müssen wir
da ran also ich glaube ehrlich gesagt
die krise die die ja vor allem darauf
zurückgeht dass wladimir putin einen
wirtschaftskrieg gegen uns führt und wir
schlecht vorbereitet darauf waren die
ist so schwierig die ist so tiefgreifend
dass es da nicht dass eine instrument
gibt sondern ich glaube es ist richtig
dass wir die bürgerinnen und bürger
entlasten mit dem dritten
entlastungspaket jetzt 100 milliarden
euro ich glaube es richtig dass wir die
kleinen selbstständigen genauso wie den
die mittelständische unternehmen genauso
wie die industrie dabei nicht vergessen
sondern sie genau entlasten aber es wird
doch gar nicht anders gehen als an die
ursache ranzugehen das doch auch für
also nur listen die inselregierung ja
aber die sind die regierung diese
strompreis bremse die erklären wir
gleich nochmal gehöre eben vermeiden
dass genau das teuerste
gaskraftwerk den strom für alle anderen
also was wir vorhaben ist doch klar wir
müssen an
offensichtlich an die regulierung des
strommarkts ran also ganz offensichtlich
wir müssen erstens mittel langfristig
müssen wir uns energie unabhängig machen
mittelfristig müssen wir uns die frage
stellen damit meine ich die nächsten
wochen und monate auch wie erhöhen wir
auch das angebot zu kriegen wir günstige
energie her deswegen diskutieren wir
gleich wahrscheinlich auch noch über
kernkraftwerke und anderes aber all das
wird nicht ausreichend kurzfristig weil
die lage die ausgangslage so schwierig
ist wie sie ist und natürlich müssen wir
ans design des energiemarktes ran müssen
die regulierungs fehler heil und diese
strompreis
wieso natürlich recht nicht vor allen
dingen daran erinnern dass vor drei
wochen ich bei diesem vorschlag dass die
sogenannte merit order das ist dieses
prinzip das teuerste kraftwerk am netz
bestimmt die preise an strom wagt das
auszuhebeln mir vorgeworfen wurden ist
wie ich denn so etwas fordern könnte
solche schwere markteingriffe zu machen
ich bin ja froh darüber dass es
inzwischen eine tiefe einsicht in der
bundesregierung gegeben hat dass das ja
wohl geht aber was jetzt wesentlicher
ist als die schlaumeierei ist dass wir
natürlich wissen dass sich der die
strompreissteigerung nur ein element der
wirklich hohen energiekosten belastung
ist weil wesentliche teil der wärmemarkt
und innerhalb des wärmemarktes der geist
der gaspreis der sich inzwischen
verdreizehnfacht hat zuvor krisenzeiten
ich habe
zu recht ganzes vermögen gilt ja umso
mehr dass jetzt der dreh und angelpunkt
ist und dann bin ich ganz mal frau
schwesig dass wir jetzt vor allem ganz
schnell anders runterdrücken der
gaspreise ran müssen so und da verstehe
ich nicht warum es so problematisch ist
darüber zu reden ob man das
kontingentiert das deckelt welches
modell man auch immer findet und im
übrigen um das zu ergänzen wie das
modell funktioniert geht es auch nicht
darum dass einfach nur steuerlich zu
subventionieren denn sie haben ja
versorger dazwischen die auch
tatsächlich die preise bezahlen müssen
und unser vorschlag sieht aber vor und
das müsste eigentlich auch der fdp sehr
sympathisch sein dass wir halt diese
differenz kosten die dann zustande
kommen dass wir die über einen fonds
über einen längeren zeitraum abdämpfen
und verlängern und sozusagen diese
momentane spitze diese schocksituation
über einen längeren zeitraum sind das
würde auch der industrie im übrigen oder
der gesamtwirtschaft habe nicht so
wirklich um einen schein dissenz weil
genau das haben wir ja vereinbart dass
wir sagen wir wollen jetzt eine ich
nehme das mal negative eeg-umlage
einführen und anschließend begriff
strommarkt daran dass über den
strompreis bremse den privatpersonen und
den personengesellschaften den kleinen
und mittleren unternehmen zurückgeben
der industrie über die senkung der
netzentgelte das ist jetzt nötig
idealerweise im europäischen geleitet
das ja auch in welche richtung die
eu-kommission diskutiert ja wir müssen
auch bei gas und wärme ran und da ist ja
heute in ihrer beider anwesenheit auch
eine kommission eingesetzt worden mit
der wirtschaftsweisen frau grimm ich
glaube ich sehr durch kluge beiträge der
foto herrn russwurm und herren
vassiliadis und da muss natürlich
vorankommt das heißt vorankommen hier
irgendwie relief bringen es gibt richtig
reden über jetzt wie hilft können jetzt
unternehmen sie haben den befund wir
kehren dahin wieder zurück sie haben den
befund von herrn roos form gehört sie
haben auch gehört was die unternehmer
und unternehmerinnen sagen und es sind
ja nicht nur die bäcker sondern es sind
ja auch firmen die etwa herstellen
beispielsweise und dafür sorgen dass
promis in diesem land überhaupt fahren
warum brauchte es so lange dass diese
regierung verstanden hat dass auch ein
bauer oder hersteller in piesteritz
systemrelevant sein kann warum kommen
all diese vorschläge zu spät hat das was
ich frage es ganz offen auch mit dem
streit von fdp und grünen sogar auf
offener bühne in dieser ampel zu tun
nein das glaube ich nicht also erstens
ich habe ein muss form eben auch gehört
aber ich war den ganzen sommer unterwegs
in meinem wahlkreis im sauerland
da sind mittelständische
energieintensive unternehmen noch und
nöcher ist die drittgrösste industrie
und handel somit beschäftigt das seit
wochen und monaten
und ich glaube alle kollegen auch in der
regierungskoalition dass wir auch katrin
göring eckardt mich so sehr wir uns auch
persönlich schätzen wahrscheinlich
gleich zu manchen fragen in der
energiepolitik kernkraftwerke zum
beispiel unterschiedliche positionen
haben ich glaube das müssen wir
aushalten weil wir ja in einem
parteiensystem leben dass die wähler
gewählt haben was auch glaube ich okay
ist weil es die neue realität ist wo
unterschiedliche parteien zusammenkommen
und die dürfen auch unterschiedliche
positionen diskutieren ich glaube zum
beispiel bei den kernkraftwerken
kommt gerät wir haben auch diskutieren
über entlastungen den sommer und dann
haben wir ein gemeinsames
entlastungspaket jetzt auf den weg
gebracht was glaube ich gut ist und wo
wir uns einig sind und genauso wenn er
sagt wir müssen ran an die energiepreise
und haben jetzt den vorschlag auf den
weg gebracht den wo jetzt der
wirtschaftsminister glaube ich hoffe ich
und gehe ich von aus tag und nacht daran
arbeitet dass wir das jetzt in die
realität bringen das bringt ja nix und
west beschließen irgendwo als
koalitionsbeschluss sollen wir müssen
uns ja operativ machen nur die bürger
konkret und die unternehmen entlang und
man muss es vor allen dingen verstehen
spiegel online macht heute auf mit der
überschrift das wahrscheinlich die
gasanlage insgesamt wackelt ich will nur
sagen was ihr angebot ist ein
substanzielles angebot an die beiden
tarif partner sind die 3000 euro heraus
form vielleicht können wir das noch mal
sagen stichwort auch die arbeitnehmer
brauchen natürlich mehr geld in der
tasche und einen reallohnverlust zu
haben wird es möglich sein und wie
vielen firmen wird es möglich sein 3000
euro brutto gleich netto an die
arbeitnehmer auszuzahlen egal ob
gestaffelt oder ad hoc um erst mal ruhe
in die arbeitnehmer situationen zu
kommen aber ja erst mal glaube ich wurde
ganz viel richtiges gesagt das bringt
aussortieren kann wir müssen ein paar
dinge gleichzeitig angehen das macht es
kompliziert wir brauchen kurzfristige
lösungen wir brauchen mittelfristige
lösungen die auch eine perspektive für
unternehmer geben warum
nicht darauf vertrauen dass es
weitergeht wenn ich jetzt
zusammenkneifen und da ist der teil
was können wir denn den bürgern an
unterstützung und bürgerinnen zukommen
lassen war ja ein ganz wichtiger und
deswegen auch wenn es den einen oder
anderen wundert die entlastungs paket
waren richtig und wichtig und sie finden
um ihre
absolut 3
jetzt gibt es im rahmen dieses prozesses
ein angebot der bundesregierung so habe
ich das verstanden dass bis zu 3000 euro
einmalzahlungen von steuern und abgaben
befreit werden will gibt es
tarifverhandlungen demnächst in großen
tarif partnerschaften da wird man dann
sehen wie man mit diesem angebot um geht
um klarerweise die 100.000 unternehmen
in deutschland allein in der industrie
wenn ich jetzt alle handwerks und
handelsunternehmen noch mit dazu nehme
dann wird die zahl gleich noch viel
größer die sind ja nicht alle gleich da
gibt es welche die gut verdient haben
und gut verdienen
das wahrscheinlich leichter fällt
tarifverhandlungen was gleich bleibt der
fällt aber es gibt auch unternehmen die
wirklich sagen wir stehen so nämlich
noch ein an der wand das ist in diesem
angebot zum teil adressiert zum beispiel
dadurch dass muss nicht eine
einmalzahlung sein sondern es wird einen
zeitraum geben in denen es zahlungen
geben kann bis zur summe von 2000
vielleicht hilft das dem einen oder
anderen unternehmen das auf die reihe zu
kriegen aber innerhalb der 100.000
industrieunternehmen gibt es alle
unterschiedlichen situationen und damit
wird man umgehen müssen und alle sind
unterschiedlich energieintensiv frau
göring-eckardt wird gleich der frage
würden sie denn denken dass arbeitgeber
zu hauf jetzt darauf eingehen und sagen
das ist erstmal ein gutes mittel um
meine arbeitnehmerschaft zu beruhigen
und wie viele können es gar nicht mehr
es gibt ein gutes prinzip in deutschland
wie wir zur lohnfindung kommen dass in
tarifverträge und tarifverträge zu
verhandeln heißt halt nicht dass man
einfach irgendwie wie man lustig ist
geld verteilt sondern dass man sich
gemeinsam an einen tisch setzt und nach
sinnvollen und klugen lösungen sucht und
deswegen geht es in der tat nicht um
einmalzahlungen und es geht auch nicht
unbedingt um laufende tarifverträge
sondern es geht insgesamt darum wie
zusätzliche zahlungen erfolgen können
der ruß form hat recht die situation in
den branchen ist sehr unterschiedlich zu
bewerten und deswegen sollte das auch
weder irgendwo in der politik zentral
entschieden werden auch nicht heute
abend hier zwischen uns sondern bei
denen die das tatsächlich seit
jahrzehnten
nämlich in den branchen und es geht um
zusätzliche zahlungen die man eben in
raten oder halt eben auch wie auch immer
aussagen kann und jeder tarifvertrag
kennt im prinzip heute schon so etwas
wie öffnungsklauseln im übrigen gerade
da bin ich mal an die hafenarbeiter
erinnern darf da gab es ja sehr heftige
diskussionen darum da gibt es einen
tarifvertrag der sehr differenziert den
sozusagen a b c klassen der der der
betriebe und so kenne ich das von den
tarifvertragsparteien von uns
gewerkschaften dass wir in diesem sinne
verantwortliche abschlüsse machen aber
nochmal das hat nichts unmittelbar mit
den laufenden tarifverhandlungen zu tun
sondern ist wir müssen ja auch die
beschäftigten erreichen die in branchen
arbeiten in denen momentan verhandlungen
nicht geführt werden sie sind das ist
ganz interessant wie sie sagen sie waren
denn auch vor einer deindustrialisierung
dieses landes auf der einen seite und
sie sagen auf der anderen seite wir
werden streiken wenn die arbeitgeber
nicht auf unsere forderungen eingehen
welche herzklappe welcher gedanke ist
der vordringliche also wenn die
situation für einzelne unternehmen in
diesem land so schrecklich ist dass sie
das land verlassen dann gleichzeitig für
höhere löhne zu plädieren oder kriegen
sie diese beiden sätze gut zusammen ich
krieg dich ganz wunderbar zusammen zum
einen weil die inflation und die
drohende rezession
eben nicht lohn getrieben ist sondern
sie ist energiepreis getrieben und
deswegen können wir auch nicht über
löhne bösen was einen eigentlichen
krisen management notwendig ist wir
haben immer gesagt wir brauchen eine
sozusagen doppelgleisigkeit kaufkraft
stabilisieren durch reallohn
stabilisierung denn wem wäre hier im
land geholfen wenn wir jetzt zb einfach
eine nullrunde machen würden dann würde
ja erst recht ein nachlassen der
nachfrage und damit ein noch mal
zusätzlicher rezessions treiber erzeugt
werden aber wir haben auch gesagt wir
können das problem nicht alleine über
die lohnpolitik lösen wir brauchen
zusätzliche politische maßnahmen das
betrifft die privaten haushalte wie die
betriebe deswegen habe ich heute ja
mehrfach auch gesagt neben all den
interessanten und guten entscheidungen
der entlastungspaket brauchen wir etwas
was noch in diesem jahr bei den leuten
ankommt deswegen eine zweite
energiepreis pauschale aber ich sehe
auch die notwendigkeit dass wir den
betrieben denen es jetzt die in not sind
helfen müssen das machen wir aber nicht
durch lohndrückerei sondern das müssen
wir durch kluge wirtschaftshilfen machen
und das bedarf in der tat einen
breiteren blumenstrauß an
grundsätzlichen systemischen eingriffen
was den energiemarkt angeht aber auch
einen unmittelbaren hilfen nicht nur für
die kleinen mittelständler sondern auch
für die energieintensiven die innotec so
vielleicht zeigen wir noch einmal unsere
sie hat das vorbereitet
dankenswerterweise wohin sich die realen
löhne entwickelt haben weil die
verbraucherpreise so enorm in die höhe
gegangen sind das sieht man hier auf
dieser grafik noch mal wohin sich auch
reallöhne für die bürger in diesem land
entwickelt haben die ja frau
göring-eckardt nochmal der
bundeswirtschaftsminister sagt allein
für gas sind die zuzahlungen jetzt
vierstellig eigentlich brauchen die
leute in 13 das gehalt wenn sie in guten
tarif arbeitsplatz hätten um das zu
kompensieren
und insofern wächst natürlich auch
einfach eine existenzielle sorgen die
sie mit allem was sie jetzt planen
bisher in diesem jahr nicht adäquat
ausgleichen können das leben geht es ja
auch sofort zuschläge zum beispiel für
die leute die wirklich am unteren
einkommensbereich sind deswegen sagen
wir wir müssen auch über weitere
entlastungen reden verschiedenen stellen
wir haben ja auch ein erstes und zweites
entlastungspaket auch das ist schon da
und wir müssten dafür sorgen ihre sachen
sind da schon vorbei ja ja natürlich
sind sie vorbei aber wir haben es ja
nicht umsonst gemacht wir im bilde mit
nur sagen die situation ist wirklich
mega komplex und da gibt es nicht die
einfache antwort die man innerhalb von
anderthalb setzen erklärt hat sondern
wir müssen die verschiedenen sachen
klären hinbekommen und das alter
entscheidend wird sein dass der
energiepreis runter geht das ist sowohl
bei strom als auch bei gas und das ist
aber eben auch nicht über nacht mit
einem fingerschnipsen gemacht und
deswegen hätte sorgen uns nochmal an
kompliziert wenn sie mich noch eine
sache sagen weil das bei mir das so ein
bisschen
verwischt gerade wir müssen jetzt dafür
sorgen und das ist für eine grüne
wirklich furchtbar zu denken dass wir
mit kohle und mitgas über diese zeit
kommen aber das entscheidende wird sein
herum hat das vorhin gesagt die
transformations- investitionen finden
gerade nicht statt das entscheidende
wird sein dass wir damit jetzt auch
sofort anfangen damit wir nicht den ast
auf dem wir sitzen irgendwie immer
weiter ab segeln und dann hinterher
wieder in der situation von damals
hätten wir die transformation anfangen
können damals hätten wir es schaffen
können und das was wir jetzt schon
geschafft haben also ich meine man kann
auch mal sagen es ist wir sind gar nicht
so schlecht als gesellschaft diese
gasspeicher sind voll und sie sind viel
voller als es eigentlich geplant war das
ist eine ziemlich krasse große leistung
und wenn man sich überlegt wo wir waren
am anfang des jahres wo wir wahl noch im
frühjahr dass das gelungen ist ich finde
dass er dann würde herr rustam jetzt
sagen ich nehme ihnen den gedanken aus
dem und das ist auch damit zu tun hat
dass 20 prozent der unternehmen massiv
ihre produktion gedrosselt geträufelt
haben dass privathaushalte gespart haben
und ich will das auch nicht schönreden
auf graz als ich würde sagen nun dass da
der energieminister herr habe weil er
jetzt auch so zwischen den zeilen viel
kritik kommt und ob bundeskanzler scholz
und auch finanzminister lindner die
nehme ich jetzt mal für die drei eine
ampel gestanden haben es war herr merz
der im märz ein gas embargo fordert den
banken ist war sehr populär wegen der
kriegssituation und es
olaf scholz und der habe ich vor allem
die erklärt haben warum es nicht geht
dass man nämlich die gasspeicher voll
machen muss und wie viele gegner den
sommer sind die gasspeicher voll gemacht
worden auch dadurch dass eingespart
worden ist und wenn wir das nicht hätten
dann hätten wir dann würden wir nicht
durch den winter kommen also da muss man
auch mal sagen das haben die aufseher
gestanden und welche nur waren die jetzt
stimmung machen hatten da noch ganz
andere positionen und weil sie von
gesagt haben wir streiten uns immer wir
machen gerade große entbürokratisierung
für die erneuerbaren und die vorschläge
kam aus dem finanzmittel
also ich werde ja die erneuerbaren
mittwoch und und die position der
erneuerbaren also ich kann nur sagen von
wasserstoff haben wir hier auch schon
genug gehört und sofort jetzt müssen wir
gerade ganz andere dinge tun das haben
sie auch schon gesagt und wir gucken
offensichtlich auch alle gemeinsam
gleichzeitig mann oder frau gerade nach
europa wenn sie mich das noch kurz sagen
lassen das sind nun tatsächlich gibt es
einen interessanten vorschlag aus
brüssel von der eu kommission wie wir
stichwort den strompreis markt in europa
neu designen können
180 euro pro megawattstunde dann ist
schluss energieproduzenten ob atom kohle
oder erneuerbare sollen jeden euro
darüber abführen um verbraucher zu
entlasten
von der leyen rechnet mit über 140
milliarden um die energiepreise in
europa zu dämpfen
so nur noch mal damit wir das zu ende
diskutiert haben und nicht überspringen
frisch wie sich ganz einfache frage es
muss jetzt schnell gehen wird es schnell
genug gehen für die strompreise durch
die decke gehen einen deckel zu finden
einen schnellen deckel und auch für gas
es muss schnell gehen wie gesagt ich
finde man kann viele modelle diskutieren
aber ich glaube dass das jetzt nicht
noch mehrere wochen gut geht den
unternehmen auch den bürgern steht das
wasser bis zum hals sie haben sie kriege
jetzt die abschlags rechnung und so ein
bäckermeister ein bürger fragt sich wie
soll ich das hinkriegen sie sollen jetzt
abspielt das nächstes jahr neue verträge
machen und wenn jemand sieht dass er das
gar nicht leisten kann kann eigentlich
diesen vertrag nicht machen und deswegen
muss es jetzt zügig ein modell geben und
es gibt ja modelle also ich kann mich
jetzt mal wiederholen ich finde es sehr
schlüssig zusagen für ein bis zwei
jahren um jetzt mal brauchen wir einen
der geld brauchen wir den deckel auf den
grundbedarf zu herr vogel sie sind
abschöpfen fdp lange das hat vorher
vorhin gesagt wollten sie an diese über
gewinne nicht ran weil sie mit dem
gedanken einer steuer verbunden waren
jetzt heißen die dinger zufalls gewinne
und es wird von einer abschöpfung
geredet denken sie damit dass
tatsächlich ein so großer betrag geldes
zusammen kommt erstens und zweitens
glauben sie dass es schnell geht ich
glaube es muss schnell gehen und ich
glaube es kann auch schnell gehen es ist
ja was anderes also generell gewinne die
stärker sind als im vorjahr oder umsätze
die stärker sind als im vorjahr zu
besteuern da waren wir gegen da bin ich
auch gegen war das eine potenzielle
innovationsbremse hätten auch bei
montech stärker besteuern müssen der
krise das macht keinen sinn aber im
bereich des energie markt und
insbesondere beim strom müssen wir daran
das ist alles nicht schön das gefällt
mir als liberaler auf der in der
perfekten welt auch nicht aber der
energiemarkt ist auch keine perfekte
welt sondern es ist teilweise ist
schlecht geplante planwirtschaft daten
wer den letzten jahren geopolitische
naivität offenbar bei der abhängigkeit
so und dann muss man jetzt ran also
winston churchill war auch kapital ist
unzweifelhaft und hat einen zweiten
weltkrieg kriegswirtschaft betrieben
also besonderes zeiten machen besondere
nachreisen es ist ja die frage sehen sie
allerdings glaubt nein das sind wir
nicht aber wir sind in einer ausnahme
lage und putin führt einen
wirtschaftskrieg gegen lassen
dann müssen wir auch die anlage gleich
und das sage ich als liberaler
entschlossen pragmatische maßnahmen hier
vornehmen während dieser zeit und
gleichzeitigen der gedanke mit wichtigen
wie ich ganz kurz sagen gleichzeitig in
der lage sein auch zu überlegen was tun
wir damit diese phase dann irgendwann
auch wieder vorbei ist sie haben das
eben gesagt und so ein bisschen ich will
sie bleiben tolerierten ich werde ihnen
sagen der leuchten sind momentan ja
andere aber wir müssen die arbeitnehmer
genannten filmen müssen das doch
schaffen dass wir jetzt akut die bürger
entlasten bei den energiepreisen und das
wird trotzdem auch die wichtigen fragen
gleichzeitig gelöst bekommen war dass
wir das in der vergangenheit nicht
gemacht haben haben es ja in die lage so
brach ich leider sagen darf was wir
jetzt schaffen zum beispiel bei planungs
beschleunigung bei den erneuerbaren
energien bei lng terminals sechs monaten
bauermedia hin wo hat es das in
deutschland schon mal gegeben denn wer
das übertragen bekommen zum beispiel
auch auf generell andere
infrastrukturprojekte und uns dass
erhalten wer jetzt gerade jetzt diesen
herbst zum beispiel auch dass fachkräfte
thema eingehend parallel machen wir noch
ein einwanderungsgesetz aller kanada
dann sind das genau die dinge die uns
dann unterscheiden von den krisen
management vielleicht vergangener jahre
und jahrzehnte die woche hat auch die
möglichkeit macht stärkster wieder raus
heraus warum wenn die nach brüssel
gucken möchte frau von der leyen ja
nicht nur an die stromproduzenten
sondern sie hat gesagt sie möchte auch
eine besteuerung von öl und
gasproduzenten der soll 20 prozent über
den gewinnen der letzten drei jahre so
eine solidaritätsabgabe einmalig von 33
prozent gezahlt werden ist ihnen diese
eu kommission ist ihnen frau von der
leyen zu radikal ja also ich habe da ein
paar fragezeichen weil ich glaube nicht
dass ich zum beispiel saudi aramco
besonders für die steuerregelungen in
der eu
interessiert die gazprom übrigens auch
nicht
140 milliarden wenn ich höre das klingt
nach einer riesenzahl das dritte paket
waren 65 milliarden also 140 milliarden
ist auch nicht so ein so ein ticket das
dass alle probleme löst bei den
eingriffen die jetzt schnell notwendig
sind da bin ich ja dabei das tut mir weh
ein achter wirtschaftsliberaler tut mir
der gedanke an das einer preissetzung
richtig weh aber auf der anderen seite
ist der strommarkt halt ein
unregulierter das heißt der strompreis
in sonderheit ist nicht einmal der auf
dem marktplatz ausgehandelt wurde aus
angebot und nachfrage sondern das
ergebnis einer logik wie man unter maria
kennt jetzt funktioniert die nicht mehr
in einer ausnahmesituation eines
wirtschaftskrieges also muss man daran
das wird nicht so schnell gehen da muss
man auch mit brüssel schauen wie man das
auf die reihe kriegt und deswegen muss
ich eingestehen dass wir kurzfristig
dinge brauchen die noch einmal mehr als
marktwirtschaft anhänger echt weh tun
das ist eine zufalls gewinnabschöpfung
geben würde hätten sie sich auch nicht
vorstellen kann ich glaube auch glaube
auch dass dieses schon dieses wort ist
ja irgendwann es ist irre führt darum
geht es nicht es geht darum dass ein
markt design der vergangenheit für die
neue situation nicht man taucht also
muss man ändern das wird nicht schnell
gehen nicht schnell genug gehen also
muss man in der zwischenzeit die den
bürgerinnen und bürgern direkt helfen
auch hin und her muss auch sachen tun wo
ich sagt mir graust davor
und ich hoffe inständig dass wir es auch
alle so verstehen als eine
sondersituation über einen beschränkten
zeitraum und wird dann uns wieder einig
sind ein funktionierender markt ist die
beste der beste preis mechanismus den
wir uns vorstellen würden
zum beispiel bei erneuerbaren energien
in meinem bundesland
wer wird doppelt so viel strom
produziert aus erneuerbaren energien ich
bin nicht passieren wird dann
erneuerbaren das was wir alle wollen
doppelt so viel als wir selbst
verbrauchen und jetzt den bürgern zu
erklären obwohl die bürger vor ort die
belastung haben und jemand der ein
kilometer vor seinem dorf den windpark
vor der nase hat er findet ihn als
belastung da brauche ich gar nicht
diskutieren als ministerpräsidentin aber
den jetzt zu sagen wir haben gar keinen
einfluss auf die preise derzeit nicht
nur die höchsten strompreise weil die
die ausbauen belastet werden durch
netzentgelte sondern dieser strompreis
ist gekoppelt an gaspreis der ja gerade
auch spekulativ ist und den krieg
ausnutzt sozusagen das ist nicht mehr
transparent da müssen sie auch mal sagen
als wirtschaftler es hat doch auch gar
nichts mehr mit leistung zu tun das
versteht doch auch gar kein handwerker
mehr normalerweise muss das doch für
eine leistung auch einen preis geben und
das muss zusammenhängen und transparent
sein und deswegen glaube ich diese ich
empfinde das alles als extrem
intransparent und man kann es den
bürgern nicht erklären wenn wir
erneuerbare ausbauen wollen dann müssen
wir den bürgern sagen passt auf das
bedeutet dass wir energie unabhängig
sind das die einzige unabhängigkeit die
erneuerbaren und nicht fossil egal wo
sie herkommen und wir müssen einfluss
auf die preisgestaltung haben und das
haben wir zurzeit nicht und das entzieht
auch dann die legitimation für solche
machen ich habe gesagt wir brauchen ein
anderes markt gesagt wo wir uns
garantiert nicht einig sind ist das
deutschland energieautark werden kann
dem traum müssen wir uns verabschieden
schuldig hat das ist um grössenordnungen
falsch können wir es schaffen dass wir
im strommarkt sehr hohe prozentsätze
selber erzeugen kann ja dann müssen wir
noch mal darüber reden wie wir das mit
dem speichern machen für den
selbst den septemberabend aber dass wir
den teil den wir heute an energie
importieren jenseits vom strom das
verdienen alles durch eigenproduktion
außen jubels ersetzen da läuft also noch
ganz viel wasser
entschuldigt ich muss mich entschuldigen
wir haben hier heute ein anderes thema
wir möchten und wollen lösungen finden
sie können gleich darauf reagieren ich
würde sagen vielleicht zwei sätze und
dann reden wir nochmal über die
situation in der wir jetzt sind und wie
wir sie lösen apotheker zwei sätze auf
herrn russwurm sie sagen die renewables
schaffen dass ich sagt vor allen dingen
wenn wir das jetzt nicht machen und
angehen und so tun wie in den
vergangenen jahren und jahrzehnten als
ob jetzt anders machen könnten dann
kommen wir in die gleiche dilemma
situation in der wir jetzt wieder sind
und dann ist eben woanders eine krise
und dann konnten andere autark ist ein
anderer diktator und sagt tut kostet
jetzt mal ein bisschen mehr und deswegen
ist die frage ob wir uns unabhängig
machen eine existenz und überlebensfrage
ostends frage in bezug auf das klima wir
reden davon dass wir möglicherweise 2030
schon 1,5 grad erreicht haben dann ist
nichts mehr mit mir machen wir das mit
der wirtschaft und deswegen müssen wir
da so konsequent so klar so hart sein
und es hinbekommen gemeinsam übrigens
mit einer bier wirksamkeit gemeinsam
hinbekommen mit bürokratieabbau mit ganz
viel allem innovation endet auch damit
dass wir dafür sorgen dass die
genehmigungen schneller gehen dass
menschen da sind die das tun und alles
das so und am ende werden wird immer
richtig sein zu sagen putin ist schuld
putin hat uns in diese situation welt
natürlich auch wir haben uns abgemacht
war je so und dem der krieg begonnen das
mag 100 mal auch richtig sein wird man
dann nicht trotzdem sagen werden die
menschen die pleite gehen nicht trotzdem
sagen robert habeck ist schuld robert
habeck ist derjenige der sie haben das
alles schon ein paar mal gesagt tag und
nacht daran arbeitet die ganzen
versäumnisse der letzten jahre
aufzuräumen wie so ein räumkommando
nicht wenn man sich ihn anschaut wenn
man sieht was was er tut und was er
macht dann kann man nicht sagen der ist
schuld sondern das ist derjenige der
versucht diese situation gemeinsam mit
allen anderen als ja auch nicht allein
spieler mit einem riesen team im
ministerium wo man auch nur da kannst du
auch irgendwie an zum 11 noch anrufen
uns geht jemand dran und mit der
gesamten regierung dafür sorgt dass das
geht aber es geht natürlich auch nicht
nur in dem die regierung das alleine
macht das wird der werden die länder
gebraucht da werden arbeitgeber
gefragter werden arbeitnehmerinnen
gebraucht dann wird auch werden auch
ideen gebrauchen deswegen es gab gerade
in diesen tagen wieder an auch noch sagt
uns bitte wohl noch bürokratie probleme
sind und wir wollen sie lösen
offensichtlich auch beim future also
wenn man wechseln möchte nochmal von gas
zurück oder hörten die kohlekraftwerke
netz sollen die jetzt nicht mit voller
leistung ans netz können weil sie nicht
die entsprechenden genehmigungen
bekommen also da gibt es schon noch ein
bisschen nachholbedarf aber ich finde
wir haben das museum vom thema ab weil
hier wollten passiert am meisten wie wir
eigentlich die menschen
entlasten können von den hohen
energiepreisen ich kann es nur noch mal
sagen wir brauchen eine entlastung jetzt
in diesem jahr ich finde vieles vieles
richtig was gesagt wurde und was auch
entschieden worden ist das sind aber
ganz überwiegend maßnahmen die erst
irgendwann im nächsten jahr kommen und
bis dahin haben sich etliche betriebe
entschieden entweder die laden dicht zu
machen oder insolvenz anzumelden im
übrigen will ich mal an der stelle auch
die lanze dafür brechen insolvenz heißt
nicht gleich pleite gehen sondern bei
hagen das ist ein schönes beispiel dafür
makler gibt es ein sogenanntes
insolvenzverfahren in eigenverwaltung
das heißt er ist kein insolvenzverwalter
sondern da geht es darum mit dem ziel
der des fortbestandes eine lösung zu
finden gemeinsam mit den gläubigern das
kann zum beispiel darum bestehen hat
zumindest wesentliche teile auch zu
verkaufen an jemand der vielleicht noch
an der stelle sich wenn sie sagen
tragfähig erachtet da sollten wir
vielleicht auch mal darüber reden ob man
nicht hier mit dem insolvenzrecht auch
etwas unterstützen das leisten kann
damit es nicht zur pleite wäre genau das
ist ja noch immer regierung es geht um
eine entlastung in der breite der
bevölkerung wir wollen und werden mit
tarifverhandlungen und mit ich sag mal
steuerfrei 3000 in der breite uns darum
bemühen dass es eine entlastung gibt wir
können das nicht alleine über tarif und
lohnpolitik stimmen das muss eine ist so
sind als leistung der politik geben die
noch in diesem jahr deutlicher wirkt als
nur die 300 euro energiepreis pauschale
was ich den richtigen mechanismus finde
weil es nämlich auch eine progressive
verteidigung verteilung hat und ich will
nur davor warnen will ich das mehrfach
gehört habe dass man jetzt nur den fokus
auf die absoluten sozialen härten setzt
da müssen wir was tun wohngeldreform
bürgergeld reform kindergeld sicherung
alles richtig aber das ist längst ganz
tief in der heide gesellschaft wir sind
frauen
euro brutto verdient das ist ist mit
einem gesamten monatsgehalt jetzt schon
in den abschlags rechnen so frisch wie
sich sie sind interessanterweise ja auch
regierungschefin eines ostdeutschen
bundeslandes sie haben verfolgt was
ministerpräsident haseloff gesagt hat
und was herr kretschmer aus sachsen
gesagt hat die wünschen sich richtig
offen das ist ein ende dieser sanktionen
endlich geben soll wie viele menschen in
ihrem bundesland sagen ihnen das ein
sehr viele ich habe ja gesagt ich komme
gerade von einer demo die von
unternehmern organisiert war und die
aufseher
die das auch gesagt haben und ich habe
den ganz klar gesagt
deutschland hat viele jahrzehnte darauf
gesetzt dass wir russisches gas bekommen
nicht für putin sondern deshalb weil die
preise dadurch gering waren es ist ein
teil unserer wirtschaft gewesen darauf
können wir nicht mehr setzen und auch
die ehemalige bundeskanzlerin merkel hat
ja mit beiden auch die verhandlungen nur
geführt unter den bedingungen dass
russland ein weg für die ukraine findet
und russland hat einen
völkerrechtswidrigen krieg begonnen und
deswegen können wir darauf nicht mehr
setzen aber dann müssen wir auch sagen
wie es geht und das will ich auch den
sein die er jetzt immer sagen wir haben
euch das schon alles vorher gesagt auch
die haben ja keine antwort auf den
preisunterschied und der
preisunterschied ist einfach da das
sehen wir jetzt das ist noch durch den
krieg sozusagen angefeuert und deswegen
ist es wichtig dass der staat jetzt
diesen weg begleitet mit der preis
bremse ansonsten verlieren wir auch viel
unterstützung das wollen wir nicht und
jetzt zu sagen das ziel sich immer mehr
zur versorgung aus erneuerbaren energien
um ist das ringer kann ich daher wohl
preis zu reiten zu können und
gleichzeitig aber den weg dahin
beschreiben ich würde sagen
die das problem was wir zurzeit haben
haben wir deshalb weil es in der
vergangenheit nie eine energie
bedarfsplanung gehabt weil gestritten
worden ist dass man für die
übergangszeit gas braucht und ich sag
mal jetzt werden sie steht ja schon
wieder im koalitionsvertrag weil auch
dieser koalitionsvertrag dieser neuen
ampel setzte noch auf gaskraftwerke die
im übergang genutzt werden sollten
entschuldigung also nicht dass man
vorher auf gas setzte das war wohl
gebraucht irgendwas wird man hier
brauchen sie haben ist es und das
windows rechner sagen gehört zu dem
thema preis deckel und entlastung auch
noch energiesparen und erneuerbare
energien dazu und das dritte dass wir
für eine übergangszeit jetzt auch
zusätzlich energie anderen lng zum
beispiel da hat die bundesregierung
jetzt gehandelt wo hier als ostsee
standort haben zwei großen projekten und
helfen mit und ich wird es ganz deutlich
seien nicht vor allem nur für meinen
bundesland wir haben den geringeren
verbrauch und haben schon für
erneuerbare sondern für viele andere
teile auch und ich glaube dieser
dreiklang genug energie energiesparen
und preiswerte und entlassen werden kann
uns helfen in nun wissen auch sie frau
schwesig zu abhängig von deutschland ist
immer mit einem namen verbunden nämlich
mit string 2
wieso sind wir da wo wir jetzt sind
unser wohl und wehe abhängig von
wladimir putin
grillfreunde quer durch die parteien
manche waren fast schon streber da
standen russische truppen bereits an der
ukrainischen grenze
im übrigen bin ich davon überzeugt dass
es richtig ist weiter auf kritischen
dialog und wirtschaftlichen austausch
mit russland zu setzen
für nord stream zwei aber wurde kein
kritischer dialog geführt
sondern eine sogenannte klima stiftung
gegründet von mecklenburg vorpommern
finanziert von gazprom ziel die umgehung
amerikanischer sanktionen für noch mehr
billiges gas aus russland
die pflege der deutschen
industrielandschaft hat eine lange
tradition
wir setzen
und die deutsche wirtschaft die jedem
meter pipeline zugejubelt hat ist heute
im dauer jammer modus
es fühlt sich so an wie wenn auf der
titanic alle rettungsboote über bord
geworfen werden die musikkapelle spielt
im speisesaal weiter
sagte dulger riesig dass wir in diesem
schlamassel sitzen hat viel mit der
sozialdemokratie zu tun und es hat auch
mit manuela schwesig zu tun nein das
weise ich zurück dass ich finde da
machen sich einige zu einfach ich hatte
mir das ja die letzten wochen und monate
an gehört und bin ziemlich überrascht
über den einen oder anderen aber so ist
das ich will es ganz deutlich sagen und
mecklenburg vorpommern kommt nord stream
1 aus der sich viele sehr viele jahre
lang gut versorgt versorgt haben an es
kommt auch nur zwei an nordstream 2
durch noch zum 2 ist nie gas geflossen
damit hat putin kein geld verdient damit
hat der geld versenkt durch die
investition von nord stream haben wir
landseitig einen riesenvorteil strang
bis nach bayern tschechien waren
württemberg wird versorgt was wir jetzt
nutzen von lubmin ja auch ich habe auf
kritischen dialog und wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit gesetzt das hat sich
heute herausgestellt dass es ein fehler
war und dass es nicht mehr funktioniert
heute jahrzehnte hat es geklappt aber
ich würde einmal hier gesagt haben
deswegen bin ich froh dass sie bis jetzt
nochmal ansprechen
mecklenburg-vorpommern war nur für die
genehmigung der leitung zuständig welche
verträge gemacht worden sind ob eine
pipeline in betrieb genommen wird warum
juniper sich einseitig abhängig machen
lassen hat hat nicht mecklenburg
vorpommern zu fahren wollten dass der
speicher in dem drama worden sind hat
der ehemalige bundes energieminister und
die bundesnetzagentur zu verantworten
das ist nina energiebedarfs planung sagt
und dass man gegenüber gabriel den rat
der rentner auch die letzte
bundesregierung und unsere
landesregierung hat immer darauf
hingewiesen dass wenn wir aus atom und
kohle aussteigen wir noch nicht komplett
mit erneuerbaren energien versorgen
können das ist so obwohl wir schon mehr
produzieren als wir selber brauchen und
dass wir für den übergang zeit gas
brauchen das ist bestritten worden es
hieß immer wir brauchen kein gas wir
hätten viel mehr
möglichkeiten haben sondern unser
problem ist doch jetzt nicht nur dass
russland nicht mehr liefert unser probe
dass wir zu wenig alternativen haben und
für die altana wir sehen uns der
industrie stärken zum beispiel an
angeschlossen wird mit verlaub dafür ist
nicht auch noch im frau zuständig wegner
unsere fans sind heute wir rechnen jetzt
damit wir energie gas bekommen wir
helfen beim thema erneuern und er hätten
sie sogar herrn söder heute um bei heute
zu bleiben frau schwesig unterstützt
deutschland zusammen mit der usa die
ukraine sie haben im jahre 21 eine
stiftung gegründet mit hilfe der russen
um us-amerikanische sanktionen zu
umgehen waren sie auf der historisch
falschen seite das würde ich mit dem
wissen von heute so nicht mehr machen
damals hatten wir die situation dass
donald trump
die unternehmen die an der recht
staatlich genehmigten pipeline
gearbeitet haben mit sanktionen bedroht
hat und diesen sanktionen wollten wir
begehen und außerdem haben die
umweltverbände in mecklenburg vorpommern
schon bei nordstream 1 eine stiftung
gegründet und dafür ihre klage gegen
extreme 1 zurückgezogen mit der
bedingung dass nord stream 1 geld für
klimaschutz gibt und wir haben gesagt
wir wollen den nord stream 2 investiert
wird auch das ist zusätzlich geld für
klimaschutz gibt sie hatte mit dem
angriff von
russland auf die ukraine ist ganz klar
entschieden worden dass diese stiftung
abgewickelt wird wir haben gerhard
schröder verfolgt er hat mit dieser
politik natürlich viel geld verdient was
war ihr motiv was war ihr motiv sich so
zu engagieren
naja natürlich kein persönliches geld um
das man ganz klar zu sagen sondern wir
haben uns immer eingesetzt für nord
stream damit es preiswerte energie gibt
die die bürger und die wirtschaft
bezahlen können das ist das modell was
seit vielen jahrzehnten seit 1960 gibt
es gaslieferungen auch schon vor
gründung eines bundeslandes bevor ich
überhaupt auf die welt kam und
dafür wird es eingesetzt dann nicht für
putin und für russland sondern dass das
preiswert ist für die bürgerinnen und
für die wirtschaft mit dieser kleinen
parallel parallel dazu haben wir als
bundesland und da müssen sich andere
fragen ob sie zu wenig gemacht haben
massiv erneuerbare energie gerade heute
habe ich wieder nur solarthermie anlage
in greifswald ein
eingerichtet und frosch lassen das war
der bub war diese stiftungsgründung eine
idee der russen und was hat ihnen angela
merkel damals eigentlich gesagt als sie
ihr diese klimastiftung präsentiert
haben als idee
us-amerikanische sanktionen zu umgehen
wir wollten dass wir diesen sanktionen
begehen beginnen können und haben das
ganz transparent nicht nur im
landeskabinett stiftungsgründung sondern
wir waren im landtag und haben sowohl
die satzung wo alles drinsteht zweck und
ziel deswegen war auch nicht ins nichts
nichts intransparent dem landtag
vorgelegt und im landtag ist es mit den
stimmen von spd cdu und linken ohne
gegenstimme beschlossen worden ich
glaube sie dass das als verteidigung
reich zu sagen es war die stiftungen und
ich war es nicht und der landtag hat es
beschlossen und das war ganze
transparenz und noch mal die frage was
hat frau merkel eigentlich dazu gesagt
ich habe frau merkel informiert darüber
und die bundesregierung hat es ja selbst
beantwortet in der kleinen anfrage dass
sie selber dazu keine wertung
vorgenommen hat es war eine entscheidung
des bundeslandes mecklenburg-vorpommern
transparent im landtag weil es besondere
weg war und ich hab das ja schon
mehrfach gesagt und sagt das gerne heute
hier auch mit dem blick von heute und
wissen von heute würde ich das natürlich
nicht mehr so machen
noch dazu ergänzen soll dass es nicht
nur alleine dann die verantwortung von
mecklenburg vorpommern geht sondern ich
will zumindest mal ergänzend erwähnt es
war die entscheidung der bundesrepublik
deutschland aller regierungen über
verschiedene zeit phasen hinweg dass wir
aus atomkraft und aus kohle aussteigen
und gas zur brücke in die erneuerbaren
des erneuerbare zeitalter definieren das
gehört mit zu der entscheidung das sage
ich völlig wertneutral aber jetzt so zu
tun als ob da einseitig aus
eigeninteressen heraus irgendeine
sozusagen einsame entscheidung gefallen
ist dass es wirklich nicht korrekt dass
es eine ganze kette von entscheidungen
gewesen die man heute anders bewerten
muss aber es nützt am ende des tages
nichts wir sind insbesondere
abhängigkeit und wir müssen jetzt
aufpassen sie sind eigentlich sekunde
folge hat es vielleicht haben sie in
niedersachsen politisch zu hause in der
sozialdemokraten sie mich nicht mit gerd
schröder habe ich nichts gar nichts mit
aber ich hier ist meine frage eben in
der sozialdemokratie niedersachsens zu
hause wie solidarisch sind sie heute mit
der ukraine frau verhindern es wurde
gerade angetragen es wurde gerade wurden
panzer angefragt olaf scholz hat das
abgelehnt für die bundesregierung würden
sie sagen alle kraft alle militärische
kraft die zur verfügung steht in die
ukraine also was ist jetzt mit
niedersachsen zu tun da habe ich jetzt
nicht ganz verstanden aber in kandidat
oder so ich bin politisch ich sitze als
dgb-vorsitzender bin auch dort politisch
zu hause und ich bin wie viele andere
gewerkschafter auch mitglied einer
partei
und ich kann ihnen sagen davon
unabhängig stehen wir als gewerkschaften
in voller solidarität zu der zudem
verteidigungskampf den die ukraine und
ukrainer führen wir sagen auch ganz klar
dass die sanktionen gegen russland
richtig und berechtigt sind da sind wir
uns auch einig mit der wirtschaft was
wir sehr begrüßt haben dass es dort eben
nicht einen viel stimmen chor gegeben
hat und was die verteidigungspolitischen
einschätzungen geht angeht also da maße
ich mir anders als ich das in den
vergangenen monaten von so einigen
bundestagsabgeordneten gehört habe nicht
an dass er wirklich in jedem technischen
einschätzung jedenfalls ist von göring
eckardt dran aber es ist wichtig die
ukraine zu unterschiedlicher unter daran
führt auch kein weg vorbei weil es nicht
um die ukraine geht die irgendwo ist
sondern weil ich will dass einmal noch
mal sagen die verteidigen gerade unsere
freiheit und demokratie das ist europa
das es in europa und deswegen ist es
auch richtig und notwendig ich will eine
sache sagen in bezug auf die
vergangenheit und manuela schwesig hat
das ja ganz oft erklärt und erklären
müssen und ich glaube es gibt auch noch
einen untersuchungsausschuss der noch
läuft und deswegen sind diese fragen
auch wichtig sie sind aber auch wichtig
für die zukunft der krieg in der ukraine
gegen die ukraine von russland der hat
2014 begonnen und ich möchte nicht dass
wir noch mal in eine situation kommen wo
wir so tun als ob das irgendwie
vielleicht doch weg zu moderieren und
danach ist nord stream zwei angefangen
worden zu bauen und es ist in einer zeit
verteidigt worden als navalny
festgenommen worden ist als smh 17
abgeschossen worden ist als wir den
tiergarten nord hatten als wenn dem
memorial verboten worden ist alle diese
auf der krim eingenommen worden ist der
das tornetz beck also diese ganzen dinge
sind passiert und wir haben nicht
ausreichend ich sage es mal wir obwohl
ich wirklich auf der anderen seite war
und seit 2014 im bundestag immer wieder
reden gehalten habe in denen ich genau
so wie übrigens annalena baerbock in der
außenpolitischen auseinandersetzung für
diesen wahlkampf deutlich gemacht hat
putin wird diesen wirtschaftskrieg auf
der energiefrage mit uns führen er wird
ihn gegen uns führen sind es ist es
natürlich blöd in so einer situation
recht behalten zu haben darum geht's mir
geht's darum da hätten wir früher
reagieren müssen deutschland hätte
früher die unabhängigkeit
auch die deutsche wirtschaft hat sehr um
dieses billige gas gerungen sich sehr
dafür eingesetzt das sagt heute angela
merkel gefragt und ungefragt dass sie
damit offensichtlich auch wirtschafts
interessen und bedürfnisse befriedigt
hat wie gucken sie da heute drauf auch
ex vorstand von siemens die landesschau
erstmal als ingenieur auf unserer uns
gefällt oder nicht die effizienteste art
große mengen energie zu transportieren
ist gas durch moleküle durch röhren
zusteht und deshalb fanden sie das so
toll über viele ja jetzt jetzt kann man
natürlich im nachhinein lange darüber
streiten hätten wir erkennen müssen dass
da im kreml jemand sitzt der einen
wirtschaftskrieg gegen uns vorbereiten
ligna noch gesucht ich habe sie nicht
besuchen sie halten die persönlich nicht
ins wo er die deutsche delegation waren
recht möglich ja aber wenn man in dieser
zeit gesagt hätte man kann russland und
der russischen regierung nicht trauen
und wir sollten eine eskalation gegen
russland führen hätte man wahrscheinlich
auch völlig zurecht einige gegenstimmen
jetzt müssen wir aufpassen dass wir
nicht die schuld diskussion bei uns
führen weil das nämlich auch in der
öffentlichen diskussion viel leiten dass
der schuldige da wir in diese situation
gekommen war die frage und an der haben
eben auch etwas einen anteil